HAVE TO GET PRETTY PHYSICAL
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE
I'VE GOTTEN PHYSICAL.
- DUDE, DON'T EVEN WORRY
ABOUT IT, I BROUGHT WEAPONS.
I BROUGHT WEAPONS.
- REALLY? OKAY.
- LOOK, CHECK IT OUT.
I GOT A SLINGSHOT.
- COOL, I'LL TAKE THAT.
I'LL TAKE THAT,
UNLESS YOU HAVE
A GRENADE LAUNCHER.
- WELL--WELL,
I HAVE SOMETHING BETTER.
I HAVE THE TETANUS BALL.
IT'S A TENNIS BALL
WITH RUSTY NAILS IN IT.
- OKAY, I'M GONNA WANT
THE SLINGSHOT
'CAUSE THIS LOOKS
PRETTY [bleep] STUPID.
WHAT ARE YOU--
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO THROW--
HOW ARE YOU GONNA PICK
THAT BACK UP, MAN?
YOU'RE GONNA--YOU'RE GONNA
TETANUS-IZE YOURSELF.
- NO, NO, SEE, THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE NOT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
I HAVE A PROTECTOR GLOVE
THAT YOU WEAR,
SO MAYBE--MAYBE YOU SHOULD THINK
THAT OVER BEFORE YOU CALL--
- VERY, VERY SMART MOVE.
- THANK YOU.
- BUT ALSO,
I WILL TAKE THE SLINGSHOOT.
- WELL, NO,
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD
BECAUSE YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW TO SLING-SHOOT.
- WELL,
DID YOU SEE MY PRACTICE RUNS?
- WELL, I DID,
AND IT DIDN'T LOOK RIGHT.
- NO, IT LOOKED PRETTY GOOD.
- OKAY. YOU HAVE NO AMMO,
SO YOU CAN'T--
- GIVE ME! GIVE ME!
- NO, FINE.
- AAH!
- ADAM?
ADAM?
OH, OH, MY, OH, MY--
- HELP ME!
- ADAM! OH, MY GOD!
- HELP! HELP ME!
- UH, YEAH,
JUST GIVE ME THE SLINGSHOT.
AND HOLD THE BACK.
- NICE TRY! CUT ME DOWN!
[screaming]
- ALL RIGHT, JUST--
WELL, DON'T BREAK YOUR NECK!
HELP!
MY FRIEND IS CHOKING!
DERS?
- BLAKE?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
- WHAT? YOU'RE THE CHEATER?
- YEAH, I'M THE CHEATER, OKAY?
AT THE STORE THE OTHER DAY,
SHE GAVE ME
A OVER-THE-PANTS H.J.
AND, DUDE, YOU SHOULD HAVE SEEN
WHAT I DID IN MY PANTS.
- REALLY?
- UNREAL.
I JUST, LIKE,
BARFED OUT OF MY THING.
- NO WAY.
HOW MANY OUNCES ARE WE TALKING?
LIKE A, LIKE A GUSHER'S WORTH?
OR LIKE A CAPRI SUN?
- LIKE FIVE BUSTS
OF I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH.
- OH, THAT'S WHY YOU WERE
WEARING SKI PANTS.
YOU WERE DEALING
WITH THE STAIN PROBABLY.
DUDE, NOW I GET IT.
OH!
ADAM, ADAM!
ADAM'S CHOKING, HE'S DYING, MAN.
WE GOT TO CUT HIM DOWN.
- WHAT ARE YOU TALKING--
- COME ON, COME ON!
- WHAT?
- GO, GO, GO!
GET SOMETHING SHARP,
SOMETHING SHARP.
- HERE, HERE, HERE, HERE,
HERE, HERE.
- OH, COME ON.
HURRY, HURRY, HURRY.
COME ON, COME ON!
HE'S RIGHT THROUGH HERE!
- WAIT, MAN, YOU'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO RUN WITH THESE.
- I KNOW! NO!
- WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
- JUST DROP THE STUPID THING!
- OH, MY GOD.
- OH, CUT HIM DOWN!
- I GOT HIM.
- CUT HIM DOWN! COME ON!
- ADAM!
- USE SOME STRENGTH,
YOU PUSSY!
- THEY'RE NOT CUTTING!
I'LL BE BACK.
- NO, NO, NO!
MY LITTLE BABY!
MY LITTLE BABY! MY LITTLE ANGEL!
[crying]
- OH, MY GOD. I GOT A BIG KNIFE!
- DERS, WHAT TOOK YOU SO LONG?
- I GOT A BIG KNIFE! BACK UP!
- CUT HIM DOWN!
- [screaming]
- OH!
[Blake and Adam wailing]
- YOU ALL RIGHT?
- I THOUGHT WE LOST YA.
- [crying] OH, GOD!
- IT'S ALL RIGHT.
- OH, MY GOD! I ALMOST DIED!
- I KNOW.
- I ALMOST DIED!
THAT WAS SO SCARY!
THANK YOU FOR SAVING ME!
- IT'S OKAY, IT'S ALL RIGHT.
IT'S ALL RIGHT.
- I HAD A REALIZATION.
I'VE BEEN ALIVE FOR 24 YEARS,
AND I HAVEN'T EVEN DONE ANYTHING
WITH MY LIFE.
- DON'T SAY THAT. COME ON.
- YOU HAVE TOO.
- I HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING!
- COME ON.
- I'VE NEVER EVEN JET SKIED
OFF A WATERFALL.
- HEY, NO ONE'S DONE THAT.
- YEAH, NOT MANY DO.
- I'VE NEVER EVEN HOT-AIR
BALLOONED AROUND THE WORLD.
- IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE.
- YES.
- [crying]
I'VE NEVER...
EVEN SEEN THE EXPENDABLES.
- WE DID, THOUGH.
ON VALENTINE'S DAY.
- WHATEVER THE POINT IS,
I NEED TO DO MORE BADASS STUFF!
AND WATCH MORE CLASSIC MOVIES.
I HAVEN'T EVEN SEEN
BEAUTY AND THE BEAST
IN, LIKE, SEVEN YEARS,
AND THAT WAS MY FAVORITE MOVIE.
- OKAY.
- AND I'M BLOWING IT!